voici une tablette qui permet de
regarder votre contenu en trois
dimensions on a vraiment l'impression de
profondeur qu'on rentre dans l'écran que
le contenu sort c'est vraiment ça qui
est génial alors c'est une lumière qui
me présente c'est la Nubia pas 3D et là
ils sortent une petite documentation
avec qui permet de comprendre réellement
ce qu'on peut venir faire avec alors la
technologie elle est très simple en fait
vous avez deux petites caméras qui va
venir repérer vos yeux qui va créer du
contenu 3D à partir du contenu 2D ça
c'est vachement cool alors ils nous
disent que ça peut servir bien
évidemment pour les professionnels
notamment pour le luxe on va l'avoir
également pour tout ce qui va être
tourisme vous voulez vous projeter vous
êtes plus en immersion à l'intérieur
pour l'éducation bien évidemment pensez
aux architectes pour la conception en 3D
pour venir voir dans les bâtiments ce
qui se passe et puis bien évidemment
pour tout ce qui va être divertissement
film c'est vrai c'est une tablette 12,4
pouces et de la résolution de 2,5/4 ce
qu'on était au CES Asus a montré déjà un
PC avec un écran 3 dimensions qui va le
traquer chacun de vos yeux pour vous
sortir un contenu totalement adapté vous
déplacez le contenu vous suite un peu le
même principe parce que j'en comprends
ici aujourd'hui chez Nubia vous
dites-moi ce que vous en pensez ce que
vous pourriez aller sur une tablette en
3D est-ce que vous pensez que c'est une
évolution possible en tout cas marquez
le moi dans les commentaires